[Music]
three days to the Oscars and camera just
vote with the night's main man host
Jimmy Kimmel yes I did and here's the
thing 35 million people approximately
will be watching in the States alone
Nancy but we talked about that one guy
who's long-running rivalry with Jimmy I
mean we cannot get enough up we heard
your fighting words
for Matt Damon yeah but I just want to
make sure that you're aware he told UT
specifically that he is absolutely
rooting against you it's pretty
unprofessional and not very funny he's
so sad he's such a sad well person
Michael Sartain wife who's a lovely
woman
yes I'll live with him I said I feel
sorry for the Great Wall of China that
it had to be in a movie with him yeah I
really I have a lot of sympathy for that
guy I'm praying for him right now give
me one second well we don't have much
time so make it quick pretty sure
insulting Matt from the Oscar stage this
Sunday is high up on Jimmy's hosting
checklist number two on the list might
be embarrassed the person who wrote my
lines only problem is she's also his
pregnant wife when I hosted the Emmys I
had my parents thrown out of the theater
and they thought it was a joke but it
wasn't so I'm sure in the back of her
head somewhere she's worried that
something might happen next thing to do
make the kids proud
Jimmy's two oldest will be at the show
but two-year-old daughter Jane she'll be
at home she wouldn't understand why she
couldn't get on stage and grab me during
this but that could make great TV you're
right it could also be a disaster and
finally the last item on the list try
not to get pranked by your wife again
safe to say this would be a bad time for
Rihanna or or Britney to come and wake
you up in your bedroom at night whenever
that happens I go to sleep the next
three nights in a row a little bit
concerned that Beyonce might step on my
head before am